There are several types of caches
when it comes to which blocks can be
placed where in the cache.
The cache examples we have seen so
far are the fully associative caches.
In this type of a cache,
any block from memory can be
placed into any line in the cache.
So if the cache has room for 16 lines,
then we need to search up to 16 tags
in order to find whether the block we're
looking for is actually in the cache.
The opposite of that is
a direct-mapped cache where for
a given block that is exactly one place
in the cache where that block can go.
That means that we only need
to check one line in the cache
if it contains that block because that's
the only line that it can possibly be.
Different blocks, of course, will still
be able to map to different lines, but
a particular block can only go
into one place in the cache.
And then, of course, there is the middle
ground between them, which is called
a set-associative cache, where there
are N lines where a block can be.
Now, N typically will
be larger than one and
smaller than the total number
of lines in the cache, so
we can really view the direct-mapped
cache, as a case of a set-associative
cache, where N is one and
a fully associative cache is an extreme
case of a set-associative cache where
N is equal to the lines in the cache.
But what we normally call
a set-associate cache
has a relatively small N compared to
the number of blocks in that cache, yet
that N typically is two, four or
eight so it's larger than one.
Now let's look at each of
these types of caches.